inspired by the traditional Japanese art
form of origami or folding paper
researchers have developed a way to coax
flat sheets of composite materials to
self fold into complex robots that crawl
and turn in the experiment the
researchers robot self assembled from
flat sheets of paper and shape memory
polymers which change shape when heated
above 100 degrees Celsius into which the
embedded electronics the flat composite
transformed into a dynamic functional
machine in about 4 minutes it then
crawled away at a speed of about 5.4
centimeters are over 2 inches per second
and it also turned all without human
intervention no previous self folding
approach has yielded a machine that can
function without additional outside
assistance the study which appears in
the journal science reports that this
new approach which is both efficient and
versatile allows researchers to quickly
produce complex robots that are scalable
to different sizes and are also very
strong for their weight